at six at an increasing rate cannabis is
sending consumers to local emergency
rooms we dug into the issue to find out
why
as the strength of the THC in cannabis
has skyrocketed so has the need for a
trip to the ER for some that partake
there's definitely an uptick when
compared with people who don't use
cannabis users were 22 percent more
likely to end up in the ER
Emergency Physician Dr Roger Martinez
sees it firsthand typically it'll be
something psychiatric
anxiety agitation sometimes they'll have
chest pain or they'll have palpitations
nausea vomiting with pot legal in 19
States many cannabis users just don't
know how much stronger marijuana has
become with higher levels of THC the
psychoactive component in cannabis not
on the high is more but also the
potential side effects are also can be
more extreme decades ago the THC level
was two to three percent today anywhere
from 15 to 30 percent studies show this
highly potent cannabis can increase the
risk of anxiety depression and suicidal
ideations I didn't know that it could
cause
psychological issues you see a lot of
people who have never taken cannabis
before it's the whole spectrum is it all
the way up to 80 years old from kids to
in their 80s typically patients are
treated with gentle sedation IV
hydration and time they're just like you
know what I didn't expect that I don't
think I'll ever do it again when taken
excessively this much more powerful
cannabis can also negatively impact a
developing brain
study out in New Zealand showed that
heavy marijuana use in adolescence will
shave off about six to eight IQ points
doesn't sound like a lot but that's the
difference between an a student and a b
student doctors say moderation and
knowledge of the drug strength are the
keys the Edibles are kind of scary
because you they look like candy and
brownies and so you don't know a 50
milligram
edible will look the same as a five
milligram so you really have to look at
the dosage over 22 million Americans use
cannabis last year most did not end up
in the ER marijuana also has medical
benefits for example treating seizures
or inflammation marijuana has some
legitimate medical uses it's great for
insomnia sometimes people use for
anxiety anti-nausea pain reduction so
yes in moderation if used responsibly it
can help a lot of people however the
risk associated with higher THC levels
needs to be communicated to the public
especially young people it definitely
would help if there was more information
in education to the general public about
it I'm gonna have to talk to her and
hope that we have an open an honest
relationship and let her know that she
can come to me and
and just have a conversation
now there are other methods of course of
consuming THC such as vaping where the
concentration even higher some
cartridges actually go up into the 90
percent potency range this all also
carries the increased risk of needing
medical attention especially for
children and teens according to several
studies